so after multiple denials the New York
Times and CNN are both reporting now
that Saudi Arabia is going to admit that
yes journalist for The Washington Post
American resident Jamal shogi did die at
their Embassy in Istanbul Turkey and the
implications are very far-reaching to
say the least we talked yesterday about
the story and we talked yesterday only
about what we knew at that time which
was that although everything pointed to
Saudi Arabia having a hand in and likely
being responsible for the death of the
journalists they had vehemently denied
it multiple times including reportedly
to Donald Trump and we spoke about the
geopolitical implications we talked
about the economic implications and a
lot more and at this point on the facts
nobody should be surprised that
Khashoggi died in Saudi custody or at
the hands of the Saudis that's been
pretty obvious for days and the way
specifically that Saudi Arabia according
to the reporting we have right now from
the New York Times and CNN and this may
change by the time you listen to this or
you watch this
Saudi Arabia is going to frame this as
it was an accidental death due to a
botched interrogation at the Embassy in
Istanbul now there is also visual
evidence of him entering that embassy in
Istanbul which we are we have on the
screen behind me for our television and
video audience and as a reminder before
we get to sort of the full explanation
that we're anticipating from the Saudis
yesterday I played video for you of
Donald Trump proposing really in a way
that provided cover for the Saudis that
it could have been random rogue killers
amorphous nameless unknown rogue killers
who took the journalist out here's just
a reminder of what Trump said yesterday
that being said
firmly denied any knowledge of it he
didn't really know maybe
I don't want to get into his mind but it
sounded to me like maybe these could
have been broken killers who knows we're
gonna try getting to the bottom of it
very soon but his was a flat denial
yeah so did Donald Trump say this
sincerely when he said it yesterday if
so it would suggest that Saudi Arabia
was directly lying to Trump personally
and we would hope that that would have
repercussions but we'll get to that
Saudi Arabia initially again saying they
know nothing about it
had nothing to do with it despite
information from very early on that one
of the few places that khashoggi went
when he was in Istanbul was to the Saudi
embassy there and specific information
suggesting he was not only murdered but
also dismembered there new explanation
is reportedly again as I mentioned and
alluded to this was an interrogation
that they were doing of Jamal shogi but
the interrogation went wrong and he
ended up dead and as the details come
out the story gets even more bizarre
Turkish officials are claiming and
believe me I know that when the Turkish
officials claim something we have to be
cautious and skeptical Turkish officials
say that a Saudi autopsy specialist
entered the country carrying a bone saw
in a group of 15 Saudis who came into
Turkey the day that Khashoggi
disappeared this has all the markings of
and appears to be yet another
disgustingly brutal and atrocious act by
the Saudis and what is you know we often
say 50 people shot in Chicago over the
weekend but it's this one person that
got shot in South Carolina that makes
the news or 10,000 kids died of hunger
in Africa yesterday but the two that
died on the London subway make the news
consider how many people in Yemen have
died at the hands of Saudi Arabia over
the last year that doesn't mean that the
khashoggi story is an on story but it is
part it's always a media story as well
what makes the news the interrogation
gone wrong explanation that could be
right it could be it's very interesting
though like was he threatened with a
bone saw and wouldn't cooperate that
with them so he ended up getting
dismembered we have to know the details
about what it was the bone saw brought
in after he had already died in order to
you literally take him apart I mean it's
[ __ ] it's gruesome what we're talking
about here and it's also important to
understand that if Trump didn't come up
with the rogue killers theory himself
and he was really told that by the Saudi
royal family this means they're straight
up lying to the president which would
hopefully carry some diplomatic
repercussions but in the era of trumpet
it's not it's not clear that it will
rogue killers is sort of accurate in
that it's this the Saudis behave like
rogue killers right and in that sense it
is sort of accurate but beyond that I
think we know that that was not an
accurate assessment and the real problem
is that we seem to have this dictator
believing dictator friendly White House
right now and it is a story about Saudi
Arabia but as an American show this is
also a story about our relationship with
this brutal regime the story from Saudi
Arabia was never believable right
embassies are very secure there are
cameras everywhere there are visitor
logs and security checks the idea that
Jamal khashoggi had been at the Embassy
and two weeks later the Saudi royal
family still just didn't know they
weren't sure or they hadn't heard that
he had been at the embassy was laughable
from the beginning the only question is
have they been straight up lying the
entire time and do we believe that it
was an interrogation gone wrong and I
think you're right Pat that it could
have been but it's also just as likely
if not more likely that it was an
interrogation followed by a deliberate
execution and they're calling it an
interrogation gone wrong because we'll
never really know and even if the Saudis
did life the Trump it's clear that he's
not going to do anything about it you
know things said during the 60 Minutes
interview that he wasn't considering
sanctions and that there are other ways
supposedly to punish Saudi Arabia over
this but he also made it clear that he
wants to keep that 110 billion dollar
arms deal and for him the life of this
one journalist just isn't worth that
money well this is important because
this is it is one journalist it is one
life that appears to have been brutally
ended early it's an American resident
it's a journalist working for The
Washington Post the idea that we would
accept as a reasonable explanation that
you know it was an interrogation and the
Saudis miscalculated and he ended up
dead whether it's true or not
is irrelevant because it's not an actual
explanation that would say to us
oh well no repercussions are warranted
the repercussions here are ones that
we've been calling for for a very long
time if it's this that causes that to
happen great it may just expose the
degree to which Trump is just enamored
and complicit with brutal authoritarians
all over the world I genuinely don't
know what the follow-up will be but you
can be sure that we are going to be
covering covering it